one of the all-time greats Bob Costas
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Bob hey rich how you doing I'm beings
from very cold yes probably windy and if
we have our fingers crossed hoping not
rainy Boston about a five minute walk
from Fenway Park last night was good
last night was low 50s would have been
fine I don't think we've got a luck out
that way tonight or tomorrow okay so
let's let's start from scratch here just
first blush who do you think has the
opportunity to perform well what do you
think about this matchup Bob well both
of these teams are really interesting
teams not just good teams but
interesting teams that can make a lot of
different moves they have versatile
players they have innovative managers
every Boston starting pitcher pitched in
relief at one point or another in the
postseason and Dave Roberts did the same
with Clayton Kershaw and in other
situations as well it used to be you did
that with a starter only in a
desperation situation two days rest in
game 7 or some sort of elimination game
now with the days off mixed in managers
do it strategically on top of that
you've got the question of what do you
do when you go to Los Angeles what do
you do with JD Martinez he can't keep
his bat out of line up so he bets who's
a superior athlete one of the great
athletes in any sport has been taking
ground balls some yesterday taking
ground balls at second base because he
did come up as a second baseman
although Alex Cora told me that he would
use him at second base only in a late
inning switch or an extra inning type
situation so to get JD Martinez as bad
in the lineup when you don't have the D
H in Los Angeles the likelihood is the
Jackie Bradley jr. who the MVP of the
ALCS would sit out those games
unbelievable Wow
that's remarkable which would be you
know I guess it's it it would be the
detriment to the Boston Red Sox
obviously for those three games how is
sale I mean with the whole business of
of him not looking sale like towards the
end of the season and then not really
touching any in the high 90s for listen
consistently in the divisional or css
and then this
I don't know if you've ever had a belly
button ring story placed in front of you
and your illustrious career Bob but this
has been fascinating with Chris Sale as
you know rich
I never went for the navel ring but
there was a brief period during the 90s
when I was paddling around with Dennis
Rodman when I did fry the nose ring and
people remember that fondly okay so you
have some experience on which to base
your commentary yeah however even
experienced members of the press were
taken in that was a ruse on the part of
Chris Sale he actually said to his
teammates this is a story I'm gonna tell
these guys let's see who buys it and a
lot of people bought it he had a stomach
virus he did not have an infection from
removing and reinserted his bellybutton
ring if in fact he even has a
bellybutton ring and while I have been
in the Red Sox clubhouse that has never
been my mission to examine second so I
can not 100% testify one way or the
other okay but that was a prank and a
lot of people fell for it
well he's obviously mentally ready for
the World Series Chris Sale so what what
do you feel of his chances against this
lineup this evening well here's the
problem they tried to manage his innings
because historically even with the White
Sox before he got to Boston he'd been
lights out from opening day till around
August 1st and then there was a
noticeable drop out drop off every year
in his effectiveness and in his velocity
in the last two months of the season and
the same thing happened to him last year
in Boston so they managed his innings
carefully and they were able to do that
because they opened up such a big lead
in early August so he's thrown fewer
than 20 innings since August first in
the regular season of the postseason
obviously he worked a little more than
that and as you said his fastball which
was averaging right around 97 before he
went on the disabled list with the
shoulder inflammation is now generally
around 92 maybe 93 but not more than 93
they don't think that he has a
structural problem in his left shoulder
they think it's just a 10
itis situation but it's going to be a
very cold night he's insistent on
pitching in shirtsleeves it's a part of
his persona so I don't think you're
gonna get seven or eight innings out of
Chris Sale even if he's effective I
think that what alex core is looking for
is six good innings and then turn it
over to the pen I mean but we're in the
day and age to Bob now where everybody
has an itchy trigger finger at the
managerial position the minute the
lineups turned over for a third time
against him it's kind of gotten a little
out of hand
Bob I'm wondering where you sit on this
whole analytics where we saw a starter
pitch to one batter in Game five of an
LCS leading to the rarity of a Game five
game six starter back to back it just
seems that this has gotten a little bit
much where do you saw I definitely like
that because that was a strategic move
that was a move to have the Dodgers set
up their lineup one way for a lefty
Miley and then pull Miley out and
counsel intended to use him in Game six
all along so I kind of liked that I
thought that was a cool chess move what
we are seeing though is a guy pitching
extremely well he gives up a bloop
single in the fifth inning now we're
starting the third time through the
lineup whoops we better go to the
bullpen and I Wade Miley I don't know
that he has a victory in the postseason
but he had several games we pitched into
the fifth needed one more out or two to
qualify for the victory had pitched
extremely well but nope nope you've
thrown enough pitches we've got a deep
bullpen and you have to say that overall
it worked for counsel because they got
as far as Game seven against the Dodgers
are we gonna see at some point maybe
you're gonna swing of the pendulum back
where's one one team's just gonna build
tons of starters and just go for it I
mean in that regard it just seems that
that now that this genies out of the
bottle where everybody's got the guys
who could throw 95 96 in the bullpen
that starters are insignificant in Major
League Baseball playoffs well I think
the fair assessment is that over the
course of the regular season you can't
do what you're able to do in
post-season in terms of use of the
bullpen because you get days off mixed
in in each series so it's a little bit
different than during the regular season
here's the advantage in the regular
season of pitchers that can go deep into
games not necessarily pitching 20-plus
complete games like Bob Gibson or Sandy
Koufax or someone like that but at least
go deep into games it isn't just that
the best starting pitcher should be
effective enough but it saves your
bullpen and if you're that bullpen
dependent
it isn't just starters who can wear down
its relievers who can wear down or get
injured during the course of a season so
when someone goes seven or eight innings
the advantage of that is hey maybe he
hung around long enough for us to build
a big enough lead that we don't have to
go to our bullpen we don't have to go to
our closer we give him an extra day of
rest all that stuff has a domino effect
over the course of a season and there
are some things like let's say Houston
even though they got beaten in five by
the Red Sox Houston has such a deep
quality starting rotation that well
certainly they wanted to bolster their
bullpen and they did with some moves
during the season you're always going to
want to have a good bullpen but they
rely very very heavily on their starters
because they're so good so I think you
you can't one size does not fit all you
got a manage or coach according to your
personnel a few more minutes left with
Bob Costas part of MLB network's World
Series coverage from Fenway Park and
Dodger Stadium including MLB tonight
airing live before and after every game
I just can't get enough a Justin Turner
Bob when you see a statistic that says
on-base percentage with a minimum of 75
at-bats in the postseason in history and
it goes Gehrig Ruth Turner that is just
unbelievable the guy is it just wears
people out and he is terrific when when
he is healthy
he wears people out and although some of
the analytics guys say there's no such
thing as clutch hitting this guy has
come through in so many clutch
situations that I remain convinced that
he's a guy you want at the plate in fact
I asked Dave Roberts that question
earlier in the playoffs I said if
you had a single guy to pick in an
eighth or ninth inning situation at the
plate no matter right-handed left-handed
pitcher who's the one guy and he said
you know we have a lot of guys who I
trust in that situation but my one guy
is Justin Turner and the thing that I
would like to see Reggie know you see
all these matchups every newspaper or
website will have matchups who keep bats
versus Goat Cody Bellinger or whatever
it may be but the big matchup is whose
beard is warm from Turner's or Craig
Kimbrel
and they're both you know as a sort of
orangish red yes you know they could
stand side by side almost be siblings
yeah I'm like I'd like someone to take a
tape measure and and settle the argument
well I mean we might find out in the
ninth inning if some of these games Bob
don't you think I mean a beard on beard
matchup would be quite something with a
game on the line exactly right you know
I mean in classic that could actually
happen before I let you go what's your
favorite your favorite story about the
two venues involved Fenway Park and
Dodger Stadium take your pick if you
want to go through your mental rolodex
of where you you just have this certain
memory of Fenway and a certain memory of
Dodger Stadium two of the older venues
in a league where everybody's got their
brand spanking new stadium with luxury
suites and boxes etc etc this is a neat
this is a neat world that one is easy
for me because I was part of the
broadcast team in Game one in 1988 and I
was in the corner of the Dodger dugout
when Kirk Gibson hit his home run I was
ready to jump out on the field and
interview somebody no matter the outcome
of the game and I saw a Gibson come
limping up the tunnel and says the end
to the dugout when no one expected him
to play he wasn't even introduced before
the game he wasn't even in uniform he
was on the trainer's table until late in
the game so I saw that whole thing
unfold and I think most people still
view that as one of the most dramatic
almost theatrical moments in baseball
history so I've had to pick one Dodger
Stadium moment it would be Game one in
1988 let me dive
a little bit more into that though so
you're in that you're in the dugout you
you're listening the broadcast you're
hearing ven and all of a sudden you look
and you suddenly see Gibson in uniform
and you saw them not it not exactly
here's here's the way it happened back
then I mean it seems almost quaint back
then broadcasters were not allowed to be
in the dugout during the game now
everybody's mic they do in-game
interviews for managers and players and
whatnot but then technically I was
breaking the rules but I didn't want us
hiding in the tunnel and not be able to
see the game so I sneaked to the very
edge of the dugout and I'm perched there
and Lasorda sees me and I always knew
what Tommy none of this had any malice
it's just who Tommy was so Tommy starts
screaming to his guys look it's bleep in
Costas even bleep and NBC thinks the
bleeping game is over they don't give us
any bleep in chance I'm trying to
suppress by laughter but they liked me
well enough to let me stay there even
though it's breaking the rules so now I
hear this is like in the eighth inning I
hear a sound from down the tunnel where
there's a batting cage so I walk down to
investigate and there is Gibson with a
ball boy who was putting balls on a tee
and he's hitting balls off the tee and
he's grunting in pain with each swing
and it's at that point that I get on the
IFB to Mike Weissman John Filippelli in
the truck and I say let VIN and Joe know
that Gibson has put his uniform on he's
taking practice swings I don't know what
that means but I guess he could
pinch-hit and that's what happened no so
what about your Fenway memory you know I
wasn't there I was watching on TV but
the Carlton Fisk home run in 1975 is
still an extraordinary Fenway moment the
Dave Roberts stolen base and what it led
to in 2004 when they were on the brink
of defeat against the seemingly
invincible Mariano Rivera and what that
led to
and Roberts himself tells a very
interesting story he wears number 30 in
honor of Moore
Will's a great Dodger of the 1960s hero
with Koufax and Drysdale and that team
and for a while he held the record until
it was broken by Lou Brock and then
Rickey Henderson he held the record with
a hundred and four stolen bases in the
1960s and he broke ty Cobbs
long-standing record and Maury wills
said something to Dave Roberts early in
Dave's career that every great bass
dealer that I have known has confirmed
for me the real test isn't when there's
an element of surprise the real test is
when everyone in the ballpark knows that
you have to steal the safe and you still
got the guts to do it
and Robert said that Maury wills voice
was in his head when Terry Francona's
sent him out to pinch run in the ninth
inning and he knew he had to go on the
first pitch that he couldn't waste any
time he did and he was safe by an
eyelash Posadas throw was good Jeter's
tag was good he was safe by an eyelash
even if they'd had replay he still would
have been confirmed as safe and it's
interesting that he never appeared in
the World Series he never had an at-bat
he did pinch run in the next game but
those were the only appearances he had
for the Red Sox in that postseason
he'd been traded from the Dodgers at
midseason and then in the offseason he
was traded to San Diego so that's all he
did
but forever he is part of Red Sox lore
and tonight when he's introduced he's
going to get a standing ovation from the
fans at Fenway Park but it's funny how
basically that pinch running appearance
is all he ever did in a Red Sox uniform
but it was more than enough so that I
guess it's only fitting that the only
cheers he gets for the entire World
Series when he's in Boston they're gonna
give me a standing ovation or at least I
hope so
when it starts and then after that I'm
the enemy and that's the way it's the
way it should be Bob you are the best
can't wait to watch your coverage on MLB
Network and let's chat down the line
thanks ray yeah you gotta that's Bob
Costas the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience